- When Machine Gun Kelly was here,
(Nick coughs)
he said he was a huge fan of you.
And he also had this to say,
so we wanted to show you.
- I went to a Backstreet Boys concert,
and I threw up on the first song
because the girls were so loud.
They were screaming so loud.
I don't know how that equaled
out to me throwing up but.
(audience laughing)
- It's overwhelming.
- I know, it happened though.
Like they came down on these hover boards,
and everyone was going so crazy.
I was going
- [Kelly] Oh!
(audience laughing)
(all laughing)
- [Kelly] They're intense,
They're intense.
They're loud.
(audience applauding)
- [AJ] Well fortunately,
- [Brian] That's an awesome story.
so that wasn't why he threw
up, so that's a good thing.
- [Kelly] No, no.
(all laughing)
- That's a good thing.
- [Brian] Yeah, it's a good thing.
- It's overwhelming.
- I just wonder if he
made it through the show.
- No, he did.
We talked about it.
No, he loved it.
But my point though is
like, it's a different vibe,
especially with boy bands, like,
it's a different ballgame, the fans.
- It is. Yeah.
- [Kelly] Coz I've had
friends that actually work on,
like y'alls tour, other people's tour,
do things like backstage.
Like meet and greet things and all.
And it's like a different kind of fandom.
Like they really are invested
like from a young age, and it's loud.
- (Kevin) It's loud.
- (Howie) Yeah.
(audience cheering)
- We like to say we have,
- [Nick] We missed that
- [Kelly] It's like a different frequency.
- [AJ] What?
- [Nick] We miss that.
- What?
We miss that.
It's been two years since the tour.
- I'm not hearing that.
- What'd you say?
- [Kelly] I know, but that's
the thing for a lot of artists.
Like everybody hasn't been able to do
what they really wanted to do.
So you're all excited
about doing this tour?
- (all together) Oh yeah, oh yeah.
- It's time.
- Excited to get back out to the fans.
- Yeah.
- It's, we've been chopping at the bit.
(laughing)
- Yeah.
- Just sitting at home, eating
(audience laughing)
begging to go out.
(inaudible conversation)
(all laughing)
- [Nick] And honestly, I
feel like now especially
with the way everything is in the world,
it's like entertainment
is so needed right now.
- [Kelly] Oh yeah.
- Like our job is so important.
- [Kelly] Yeah yeah yeah.
(audience clapping and cheering)
- [AJ] Music! music's important.
- Get people's mind off
the stuff out there.
(audience cheering)
- And it's to be in a room and,
when people that you don't know
and you're all like vibing on one thing,
I love that feeling so.
- [Nick] Yeah.
- Different kind of energy.
And we thrive on that energy, you know?
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
- I mean, don't get me
wrong, our kids were so happy
that we were home for this last two years
- [Kelly] Were your wives?
- [Nick] Our wives are glad,
our wives were glad we're not
at the house.
- [AJ] Our wives are like,
"you have to go back to work.
Please go back to work."
- I had two babies born during that time.
[AJ] Yes.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Oh, that's so cool.
I'm happy for you.